[موسيقى]
اسره
الاكدي في منزل انثى السنجاب دق دق الباب
في منزل انثى السنجاب دق دق
الباب من بالباب دق الثعلب باب الذئب
عانقه وبكل الحب هيا يا صديقي ساعدني
لناكل ابناء السنجاب شرب الذئب من التريا
وبصوت مثل السنجاب هتف اتيت يا رفاق
صاحبكم فدعوني ادخل لا لن نخدع انت الذئب
اذهب اذهب يا كذاب ما دامت ماما بالخارج
لن ندخل ابدا
اغراب في منزل انثى السنجاب دق دق الباب
في منزل انثى السنجاب دق دق
الباب من بالباب صعد الذئب لسطح المنزل من
مدخنه البيت سيدخل اشعل ابناء السنجاب
فيها النار فقفز مهرول بب الغابه يا غدار
بالعقل لدينا افكار لن نفتح باب المنزل او
ندع غريبا يدخل اي يا
ويلي في منزل انثى السنجاب دق دق الباب في
منزل انثى السنجاب دق دق
الباب من بالباب نفخ الذئب ونفخ كثير
بهواء للرمل مثير سقط الذئب من الاعياء
والثعلب مغموما يسعل اسمعنا اسمع يا ذئب
هاتفنا صاحبنا الفيل وسياتي خلصنا منكم
ويهز الغابه
و في منزل انثى السنجاب دق دق الباب في
منزل انثى السنجاب دق دق
الباب l